well a plan is on the table for another
public transportation option to get you
to downtown las vegas the boring company
wants to expand the vegas loop into the
city of las vegas city limits joe muller
is live at the convention center where
it's already in use with more on that
idea tonight joe
well that's right the convention center
here was the first place where these
tunnels were built here's a live look
this year this evening this is one of
those stations at the west side of the
convention center right now tunnels are
being built to other nearby resorts but
soon the city of las vegas will take up
the idea
we're just here on a little vacation tom
rogers is from indiana being out of town
we're not familiar with the streets he
says getting to fremont street could be
easier we actually was looking for the
monorail system
to get a trip down here but it only goes
like 3.5 miles and it stops he says
another option to get downtown may be
good and that could be happening you
always got to have options for things
the vegas loop could be coming downtown
it's already operating at the convention
center and is used to get people from
one hall to the next the boring
company's plan is to extend it around
the strip and according to the proposal
the city of las vegas on june 15 las
vegas city council will consider the
proposal to allow the boring company to
dig under las vegas boulevard and up to
fremont street it's usually an uber or
lyft and those prices keep going up
jerry bullock from missouri says the
idea of tesla's going through tunnels is
appealing it's interesting it's
interesting for sure it seems to be the
future i guess according to the proposed
map the tunnels connecting the
convention center to resorts world and
encore are already underway
it also shows a proposed tunnel to
eventually go to the airport with the
underground systems i don't know rogers
is on the fence about the tunnel idea he
wonders why the monorail never came
downtown i think the monorail extension
would be better
back out here live taking another live
look at the station for the vegas loop
here at the convention center now on
that proposed map there's also a few
stations similar to these that would be
put up downtown near fremont reporting
live outside the convention center john
muller live local now